oh you're not hungry
[Laughter]
[Music]
hi I'm Hannah and I'm the world's OKs
mom now ever since I had my second kid
I feel like date nights have totally
gone out the window but at this point
he's three years old so I have no excuse
it's time to bring them back but I get
that guilt of a working parent where
I've gone five days a week and leaving
my kids longer than I already do just
makes me feel super guilty and plus if I
had to plan a date night I wouldn't even
know where to start so I want to try
something that I think will be fun for
the whole family I'm gonna let my kids
plan my date night start to finish
though it could be four hours of just
straight playing Legos or it could
actually be something really fun long as
it's not watching Caillou I'm cool with
it so let's see what they say I don't
think my kids quite know what a date
actually is
I think Jackson's idea of a date comes
from Disney movies and in those the date
consists of the woman dressing up in a
ball gown and there's like magic and
sparkles and some fairy godmother
blesses her with a wand to like make
everything come to life
it's very over-the-top Wyatt's idea of a
date is probably like a sword fight or
something like here's no it is okay have
you guys given any thought to our date
night what do you think all that yeah oh
my gosh what do I wear to something like
this there are a lot of games to play
huh a lot of toys is Chuckie Cheese
dinner
ice-creams dinner too so Jackson made
this little joke about how we should
have ice cream for dinner on the date
and why it clearly was half listening
the whole time but then heard that
little n bit and jumped in to remind us
all
no definitely not pleased with that idea
and it was not going to happen you're
right you guys that's what you've
decided
what we're gonna do but you needed
yourself very Frenchie fancy because
it's a fancy date would you if you had a
girlfriend would you take her to Chuck E
Cheese
hey yeah so I have my collagen eye pads
on right now so you know I'm taking this
very seriously
now when I went to get dressed for this
date I really had to reach back in the
closet kind of like behind all my daily
wear to bring out something that's a
little fancy up to Jackson's standards
as a mother I feel like I shot very
practically everything I buy is machine
washable because it's all gonna end up
stained I don't own like cocktail
dresses or nighttime outfits because
whenever I go to buy one I have to
remind myself that I have nowhere to
wear it but for this we're going out got
a nice dress and I put in some effort I
got it together I got makeup on ready to
go that looks very nice he's very
excited when you realize that we kind of
have to do things out of order because
if we go to Chuck E Cheese first and
then the park it's gonna be pitch black
by the time we get to the park and that
means it's technically closed I think
they close at sundown so we're gonna go
to the park first then Chuck E Cheese
then ice cream and then we're gonna
watch Adventure Time there's a free
swing oh but they're not next to each
other because this is a bigger thing
this park is full of kids so our first
stop was the park which was the stop I
was least excited for but we did it we
wanted to make good on this date of Matt
and I went and we forced ourselves to
play on the play equipment
oh my god we're so weird you pump every
window we made sure to go on each and
every piece of equipment because I
thought that that constituted a full
Park play experience oh my god I've
never dawned on me until I actually went
and tried playing on this play equipment
that kids are a lot more dexterous than
adults and I felt most embarrassed about
the fact that I could barely get through
the monkey bars and it's hard it's hard
to do
[Music]
one two three that's driving the train
okay this is so awkward and like I
honestly wouldn't be surprised to
prepare an approach to us and like asked
us to leave we really stick out right
now and also this park is don't got it
for getting a lot of weird looks so
we're gonna go this is business this is
fun Wow at the park my first priority
was just to not make eye contact with
anyone or look at any child for too long
we had a couple fun moments it was all
around very awkward but it wasn't so off
to Chuck E Cheese cuz that's not awkward
either okay oh it's bright it's like
early bird special dinner
chucky cheese I don't even remember what
kind of food they serve there I think
they have like pizza salad the Box warm
box wine that's that's first shirt
necessary I was so hurt and disappointed
to find that they eliminated the box one
on tap
the last time I went to Chuck E Cheese
they had box wine on top that was
actually my first legal training
was box wine on top at Chuck E Cheese
when did that happen
I didn't see a press release - cheers
cheers guys so I was a little salty
about it when I first tried the wine
devastating okay so we got wings endless
salad bar two glasses orange a play path
like fifty bucks not bad such a madhouse
here that literally nobody is noticing
that we don't have any kids because it's
like full of parents sitting at the
tables by themselves while their kids
play so I like I'm kind of breathing a
sigh of relief right now almost finish
my wine already 23 ticking
I know it didn't quite dawn on me until
we got there how much fun chucky cheese
is without kids usually when we go with
the kids they're playing all the games
and I'm just kind of there supervising
eating some pizza when we went without
the kids we got to play everything and I
was there holding a beer in one hand
playing Batman whack-a-mole just living
my best life by Chucky Cheese
now I am inherently competitive and when
it's me and Matt I have to win and so
the most frustrating part about being at
Chucky Cheese with him is that he was
way better at the games than I was
and
cuz I was losing he was you know getting
them getting a multitude of tickets and
I'd had a little wine I I did a couple
of things that I'm not proud of
so mean
it was fair game I'm sorry if you leave
your tickets at the game
that's just Chuckie Cheese code of
conduct rule number six thou hast left a
tickets
it shall be claimed by the nearest
adults I got super excited at the end
we're picking our prizes and you know we
wanted to bring something back for the
kids we're excited about picking out
something really cool
it was fun and it probably was partially
due to the Chardonnay
but it was so fun he's so into this I'm
so excited we got a ball we're gonna get
these to the kids we're not keeping
they're gonna be so slight to Rockets
Chucky Cheese Rockets two balls and two
spinning top oh my gosh the boys are
gonna be so excited they weren't
expecting this I had the best time ever
I had the best time ever
now after Chucky Cheese all that was
left of the kids date idea was ice cream
and adventure time but it's 6:30 okay
huh how you feeling good so we decided
to go a little rogue and incorporate a
couple grown-up things
because what I was dressed I had makeup
on we got to do some more we were not
driving at this point we left the car at
the house and we took a ride chair to
all of these stops we were not being
irresponsible we're parents come on
okay so we took a little detour when
I've had a couple glasses of wine I like
to shop what they don't know won't hurt
that we're just expanding on our on our
date so while we were at the vintage
store I have just got completely caught
up in this night for us and we're out
and oh my gosh I'm gonna do this forever
and we're gonna do this every weekend so
I ended up leaving two fake fur leopard
coats
I'm so excited this is what I got
yeah for future date okay so we're
walking down the street this guy comes
up to us and is like to want to go to a
speakeasy he's like in front of this
dark door and we say well matt says no
and I say oh maybe and say no I just
kept down fur coat so we end up getting
into this speakeasy it's really cute we
got some mint juleps I mean David has
gone off the rails at the speakeasy we
were able to just sit in a quiet corner
and people watch I mean I think it's a
lot more of our vibe as adult parents
we're not super like I want to jump up
it down for two hours you know you just
kind of want to sit and relax little
cocktail last stop of an epic night ice
cream time
and finally at the end of the night we
got home put on adventuretime and within
30 seconds Matt was passed out
completely and that is a skill that I
swear you get when you're a parent you
can just fall asleep anywhere in 30
seconds I mean I've seen Matt just fall
asleep with a coffee cup in his hand
because he needs to I'm mad at him I'm
right there with him I was like I'm
gonna I'm gonna film this and then
that's right off myself I had a lot of
fun on our date yes thank you for
planning it yeah well it was really fun
I want to go back to Chuckie Cheese more
does that sound good in the end after
this date I'm really grateful that I
gave my kids the opportunity to do this
I had a blast and it just opened my mind
to a whole new perspective of what date
night could be now what did I learn I
learned a few things I learned first
that Matt and I can afford to go out a
little bit more often I feel like as
parents the focus is so much on the kids
all the time that you lose that
connection to each other sometimes and
you you forget to take time for your
partner and so having the date night out
of the house and just doing something
that was for us really reminded me but I
need to do more of it the second thing I
learned was I have a lot more energy
than I thought I did I think being a
homebody it's the effort of motivating
myself to go do something that's most of
the work and then once I'm out I'm there
and I'm having fun and I have energy and
so we just ended up going all night and
it was awesome
and then third I'm not even ashamed to
say that since that date we've gotten
back to chuck-e-cheese at least three
times this is going to be a regular
thing for us and the kids it was so much
fun and I really think that at the end
of the day this date plan was Jackson's
long con to get to go to Chuck E Cheese
more and it worked that's all I got for
today I'm Hannah and if you have any
date ideas leave them in the
or you can text me this is a real number
I don't always respond because I get a
lot of messages but I do read them all
and then if you'll please excuse us
we're off to an epic date night at
Jacksons elementary school at family
dance night can you tell we need date
ideas please help us til next time
are you ready to rage
[Music]